will kazarin a Noster protocol developer
and creator of the app Damas which was
the first Noster based app to make it
onto the Apple store within two days um
I was banned in China because like the
CCP I guess got wind of it pretty
quickly and they're like oh I gotta stop
this but it was it's been an interesting
experience seeing it just going through
the whole process how many uh how many
downloads have you uh seen so far
uh we're up to about 250 000
um it went up to 24 000 in Mainland
mainland China in like a day and then
that before it got cut off so if they
didn't cut off China I bet it would have
would have been much much higher if when
you say okay so it's cut off so uh
people in uh mainland China can't get it
anymore but the people who have it can
they continue to use it or has it been
rendered in operative
they can just use it outside of Damas
and outside of uh the app store right
like I remember when the relays were
getting bombarded with Chinese traffic
uh because the App Store did open there
uh the the downloads on the store for
for China dropped uh but the the relay
that we run the Chinese traffic like
remain the same yeah
um so that's the thing right you don't
need the same client it doesn't matter
if CCP doesn't like it anymore right I
mean people who just read vpns or Thor
and get around it because the
information uh network is the same
right the client is just sort of like
you know one more nice sort of
experience and shapes how you absorb it
how you interact with it but the
information system is the same much more
much like the internet right or TCP like
I mean the stuff is just flowing through
um you just find another way of tapping
into it back to the China example for a
second because I think it's worth
lingering up on since that is you know
the the prime example of an
authoritarian very powerful Authority
saying second only to uh Mark Zuckerberg
in Facebook this is not allowed I'm
putting up here just right now the the
notice that will posted uh that it his
app had been banned in China and you see
Snowden commenting down there smells
like fear
um but the reality is you know when I go
to the global feed which is like the
kind of fire hose of everything that
anyone is posting from anywhere in the
world uh to Noster you still see like
ton of uh Chinese posts it's almost
maybe even you know half of the posts uh
have you know Chinese characters on them
so clearly that's some evidence that
this protocol is fairly censorship
resistant yes
it's yeah it's going to be really hard
for them to shut down all the relays
because for instance because I was
asking some people in China I'm like do
you guys are you guys running your own
relays and they told me yes so there's
there could be like a sub Network that
we don't even see that they're using
within their country and that's so like
that's one that's a big issue is when
you go across the firewall apparently
then
um they can start tracking things but if
they're actually running their own
relays within their local communities
then they can communicate um and we
wouldn't even see that right so yeah I
mean so
um think about it this way
um you don't really have like a global
global feed right like it's not like
there's a single Source a single River
it's more like a blueville system right
so you have like multiple rivers and
you're all connected to each other uh
and and they can change paths too right
so if somebody puts a stop in one you
can reroute that to some other relay and
you can have say like a mirror relay or
a bridge relay uh that uses some other
sort of form of communication uh uh that
is not like the main internet uh for you
to to sort of create this interactivity
between the two uh mostly because this
protocol is so sort of like simple and
contained it's it's pretty clever so the
thing that you you start to think about
then is you know what are the choke
points that are that that governments
are going to try to use it I mean it
seems to me that the the relays
themselves would be that the target like
like there's going to be malicious
actors right there's going to be people
putting child abuse up there or you know
scam type Financial schemes uh trying to
like the you know funnel money to
terrorists or whatever and then the
government's going to get interested are
they going to go and start shutting down
the individual relays that Host this
stuff like is the Relay operator going
to be the choke point or the person held
liable
um or and is there any way to guard
against that and make sure you're not
going to get screwed over as the person
that's hosting this content it's just
like you know flag Theory right same
idea it's the same idea for Bitcoin
mining is you know as long as there is
an economic incentive and that's why
sort of like the Bitcoin start to play
into this somebody is going to relay
that message somewhere else right so yes
they can they can ask Amazon to take
down a relay here they can ask you know
her so like to take down a relay in
Germany or whatever but you you can't
you can't block them all and they can
all have a copy of the information so
this one is going to be a tough one for
governments to try to stop I mean you
know you look at all fact compliance uh
for Bitcoin mind blocks right they ofak
cannot oh is the stuff that it's
essentially like the treasury saying hey
this is a terrorist transaction you
can't accept it you can't mine it right
sanctions violating yeah thanks yeah so
most of the most of the miners like
still do it right so it's no different
than this I mean like half the world
doesn't give a crap about what your
government locally cares so they will
relay uh and you can attach that
economic sort of uh interest or
incentive so that they they have a
reason to do so
but does that push people out of I mean
like you guys are living in in the
developed World in oecd countries you
know if they come after you isn't that
going to have a chilling effect on uh
you know on people who are either
developing clients or or other Pro you
know programs that lay on top of the
protocols Etc
um and if they go to Amazon I mean like
if you know if if the US government if
the SEC or the FTC or the FBI
says hey you know what you're harboring
something and you have this you know you
you make a lot of money having uh you
know web servers but you make even more
money uh and you have your freedom you
know in the Amazon retail stuff is isn't
that enough pressure to kind of squeeze
the type of TR you know the type of
activity you're talking about out out of
the developed world how how's the war
against turrets going how's the war
against drugs going it's always going to
be about selective enforcement right
this guy's great broad laws and then
they essentially only enforce against
the people that they don't like with the
current government in place hey thanks
for watching that excerpt from our
conversation with nvk and will casarin
about Nostra and the future of the
decentralized web check out the full
interview in the description below and
tune in every Thursday at 1 pm Eastern
to catch these conversations Live And
subscribe to recent TV and hit the
notifications Bell to find out anytime
our videos go live